dr. Kunze fabrication he's hilarious  old-school comedian I've loved him since  I was a kid I did one of his routines  word-for-word in my fourth grade talent  show it did not go well but in my  defense I thought he actually went motor  boating with Charo my favorite  pint-sized doc huh look at this guy he's  so small he could model for trophies  that don't get any shiny you can get a  job as a lighthouse you look younger  every year and again I'm legally blind  so you do the math whoa whoa whoa who is  this hi Dickie I'm dr. Julie Dobbs what  do you say we go down to the courthouse  and change your name to wife number five  oh hey hey hey listen I got this for you  my show at the Tropicana 1978 thanks  deke I listen to these whenever I'm in a  bad mood  so always people a lot of you are late  with your time cards this week whoa whoa  whoa where'd you get this guy  bureaucrats R Us okay let's get you to  an exam room  seriously red tape and boredom had a kid  it would be that guy  you